[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to once again
be discussing the events that transpired
in the harry potter universe after the
books and films ended i've made two
videos on this topic to date parts one
and two which each cover ten separate
characters and what they got up to with
post deathly hallows today i'm going to
be continuing that trend in giving you
part three of what happened to these 10
characters after the war i'll link parts
1 and 2 in the pinned comment the new
fantastic beast films such as the
secrets of dumbledore dropping april
2022 are giving us new insights into the
beloved characters of our childhoods
releasing never before seen information
about their backstories that got me
thinking what happened to these
characters after the story had ended
today we're going to be taking a closer
look number one abba fourth abba fourth
dumbledore was a british half-blood
wizard the older brother of ariana
dumbledore the younger brother of
hogwarts headmaster albus dumbledore and
the son of kendra and percival
dumbledore aberforth had a poor
relationship with his brother as they
were both involved in a three-way jewel
involving grindelwald that led to the
death of their sister ariana when aryana
died it basically ended their
relationship as aberford blamed albus
for her death even though albus and abba
fought were brothers and fairly close in
age they were always very different
aberforth is presented by rowling in a
bit of an interesting light perhaps you
provide a bit of comic relief as in the
goblet of fire it's mentioned briefly
that aberforth has a bit of an unusual
relationship with his goats in fact he
was even prosecuted for the supposed
things that he did with goats what he
did with goats has never actually been
disclosed but what we do know about this
odd natured wizard and this shouldn't
surprise you is that after the war he
kept a low profile living about the rest
of his days tending to his goats of
course aberforth also resumed his role
as the barman at the hogshead inn where
he served a butterbeer to the future
generations of hogwarts students for
decades to come no one knows if
aberforth ever truly forgave his brother
albus for his role in the entirely
avoidable jewel that resulted in his
sister's death but i certainly like to
think so
2. fleur de la cour
fleur isabelle de la cour later flo
weasley was a french quarter velar witch
born in the year
1977 fleur is first introduced in the
goblet of fire under the context of the
tri-wizard tournament and emphasis was
placed on her because she was the
champion representing her school bobatol
shortly after the events of the
triwizard tournament in the summer of
1995 fleur took on a role at gringotts
in order to improve her english it was
here that she met one of the older
weasley children
bill who was working there as a curse
breaker
the two hit it off straight away and
nearly immediately began dating with
bill eventually proposing
the pair get married in the story but it
seems to occur just as the wizarding
world is collapsing so my question is
given that the two of them survived the
war what happened next
well it should come as no surprise that
bill and fleur after getting married
went on to have children of their own
fleur became the mother of three
children victoire louis and dominique
weasley expanding the already prolific
weasley clan even more given that both
victoire and dominique were female and
that fleur had velar blood in her veins
her daughters also possessed velar blood
this made them 1 8 vela
technically louis had the same blood in
him but it has been reinforced through
canon that velez are only women though
bill survived the war and his severe
injuries inflicted by the notorious
werewolf fenrir greyback specifically
avoiding becoming a werewolf himself it
has been expressed that he did develop
the tendency to enjoy very rare stakes
3. seamus finnegan james finnegan was an
irish half-blood wizard born in the year
1980 whose father was a muggle and whose
mam was a witch
sheamus was a fellow gryffindor sharing
a common room with the likes of the trio
and as a secondary character in the
series pops up every once in a while
throughout the entire story starting as
early as the first book sheamus helped
as best he could during the battle of
hogwarts unfortunately was able to
survive the war immediately after the
battle had ended he could be seen
sitting with dean thomas and amber fort
dumbledore
while this hasn't been confirmed through
canon i like to imagine that sheamus
ended up working in some kind of role
pertaining to pyrotechnics the young
irishman had a knack for blowing things
up after all perhaps a career in magical
fireworks
4. mcgonagall minerva mcgonagall was a
scottish half bud which born in 1935 to
parents robert mcgonagall and isabel
ross
after a chaotic first few decades of her
life involving familial issues and
heartbreak she eventually found herself
working at hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry the same school that she
herself attended in her youth we know
mcgonagall as the stern but kind
transfiguration professor that was
always quick to call out harry and ron
for being late but was also the first
person to be standing in front of and
defending her students if something went
awry mcgonagall's loyalty to hogwarts
eventually earned her the title of
headmistress after dumbledore had died
and snape had been ousted from the
school
mcgonagall played a pivotal role in the
defense of hogwarts school during the
final battle and luckily she survived
after the war ended she was awarded the
order of merlin by minister for magic
kingsley shacklebolt due to her loyalty
to the order of the phoenix once the
school overcame the destruction
mcgonagall returned to her position as
headmistress of hogwarts and stayed in
the role until at least the 2021-22
school year whether she's still there or
not remains unclear
5. narcissa lucius lucius malfoy and
narcissa malfoy or narcissa black were
the prejudiced pureblood extremist
parents of secondary and sometimes
primary antagonist draco malfoy harry's
peer lucius despite his commitment to
the dark lord was known to be a bit of a
sniveling coward which meant that
similar to pettigrew he showed loyalty
to wherever he believed the power was
after the battle of hogwarts had ended
voldemort was dead which meant that they
no longer had the security blanket that
came with any kind of association to him
this left their fate entirely up to the
good guys the rest of the wizarding
world
when it started to look like voldemort's
regime was about to fall the malfoy
family simply hung their heads and
walked away from the hogwarts grounds in
shame
so what came of them were they given
life imprisonment in azkaban or were
they forced to endure some other equally
awful fate it would appear that after
the event of the deathly hallows lucy's
and his family managed to avoid
sentencing by revealing information
names etc about the surviving death
eaters
ensuring that the wizarding world could
move forward in perfect harmony with no
more spikes in evil meant that capturing
the remaining death eaters was of utmost
importance therefore when lucius
willfully offered to reveal this
information in exchange for him and his
family's freedom the ministry of magic
which was in tatters at that point
was more than willing to take him up on
it
after being pardoned it seems as though
they kept a relatively low profile
despite no longer being openly evil they
certainly still held on to a lot of the
same beliefs that they always held and
weren't any more tolerant of muggles or
half-bloods the pair also remained
critical of draco and his wife for
raising their grandson scorpius with a
more tolerant world view
6. cormac mclagan cormac mclagan was a
british pureblood wizard born in 1979
who was probably best known for his
pompous attitude mclagan was a fellow
gryffindor just one year above harry and
was also a member of slughorn's slug
club like most gryffindors mclagan ii
participated in the final battle of the
second wizarding war fighting alongside
the defenders of hogwarts mclagan
survived the final battle and no one
really knows what happened to him after
the war
despite mclagan's arrogance throughout
most of the story we do have to give him
credit for the role that he played in
the final battle
acting as a leader and showing immense
bravery maybe mclagan didn't turn out so
bad after all
7. corp group a small giant bit of an
oxymoron there and hagrid's half-brother
is first introduced to us when hagrid
brings the trio to the forbidden forest
to make introductions hagrid discovered
his brother grope while making a trip to
the tribe of giants in 1995 on albus
dumbledore's orders the first thing i
want to address is that group did in
fact survive the battle of hogwarts and
immediately after their victory could be
seen celebrating and laughing while
students threw food into his mouth other
than not being listed as a casualty in
the battle there's no definitive cannon
answer as to what happened to group but
i do have a fairly conservative theory
you see after umbridge admins acted
hogwarts dumbledore and hagrid thought
it would be best to send group to live
in a cave in the mountains near
hogsmeade as it turns out group enjoyed
the cave quite a lot and much preferred
it to the forest where he lived
previously though group emerged from his
mountain cave to fight in the battle of
hogwarts i think that the cave was
actually a great home for group that he
simply returned to live there after the
battle
by this stage group had developed
considerably from when hagrid first
found him and even began to show an
understanding of human emotions like
happiness and joy given that hagrid
stayed on as gameskeeper i think that
group would have simply lived out his
days traveling between hogwarts school
and to the mountains near hogsmeade 8.
rita skeeter british witch rita skeeter
the extremely conniving journalist built
her infamous reputation around writing
defamation pieces full of misinformation
for the daily prophet
no one was safe from her poison pieces
even albus dumbledore who once remarked
that skeeter was enchantingly nasty we
don't have to guess what happened to
skeeter because it's been well touched
on by rolling in interviews
naturally what could stop rita from
still reporting i imagine she
immediately dashed off a biography of
harry after he defeated voldemort one
quarter truth to three quarters rubbish
it has been revealed that she also wrote
biography hatchet jobs on both severus
snape and newt's commander these pieces
were titled snape scoundrel or saint and
man or monster the truth about newt
scamander respectively
essentially rita lived at her days being
rita continuing to live and work as a
successful reporter and author
9. slughorn horus slughorn is a british
wizard with a long history at hogwarts
he was head of slytherin house resident
potions master and even the official
host of slug club
slughorn infamously told tom riddle
about horcruxes and slughorn's fear of
dumbledore finding out led to his
initial retirement from the post however
slogan later returned to the school
after a long hiatus continuing on as
potions master
slughorn played an important role in a
wizarding war fighting valiantly in the
final battle alongside his students and
peers fortunately slughorn was able to
survive and continued working at
hogwarts acting as head of slytherin and
overseeing the first year sorting
ceremony
sometime before 2016 slughorn fully
retired and he received the honor of
having a portrait of himself placed in
the slytherin common room
10. dean thomas dean thomas was an
english half-blood wizard born in the
year 1980 the son of a wizard and a
muggle mother
dean was notably in the same year as
harry potter and was also a gryffindor
student dean pops up quite a lot in the
harry potter story and it should come as
no surprise that he fought valiantly
alongside his allies in the battle of
hogwarts a battle that fortunately he
was able to survive
so what came of dean after the battle
well immediately after dean was seen
sitting next to seamus finnegan and
aberforth dumbledore in the great hall
beyond that well canon doesn't give us
any info
if i had to guess dean pursued a career
as an artist i say this because
throughout the story he demonstrates an
affinity for art and he was said to be
quite good with the quill
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel who next
comment down below until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]
[Music]
you